le 30 novembre prochain il y aura été
dit que ce sacré dans le tout nouvel
amphi de l'école centrale supélec et
j'ai eu la chance d'être sélectionné
pour pouvoir vous parler des algorithmes
du vivant il y aura aussi cédric villani
qui vous parlera de maths de santé et de
big dada ou encore sylvie mombo qui
était apparu dans l'épisode 26 sur la
série sur la démocratie qui vous parlera
de des comptes et du vivant il sera
aussi question de blocs shane de soleil
ou encore de papillons bref que du bon
la billetterie de l'événement est
indigne est sauf que mauvaise nouvelle
il n'y a déjà plus de place mais a quand
même les icônes hector qui ont diffusé
l'événement en direct
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'en tant
qu'intervenant m'a offert la possibilité
de vous offrir deux places et du coup
bah je me suis ça serait cool de faire
ça en mode défilé histoire de vous faire
un petit peu réfléchir alors oui je sais
falloir que je réponde aux défis les
quatre un jour ça viendra
en tout cas voici le défilé 5 prenez un
quadrillage régulier et enlever toutes
les lignes pour ne retenir que les
points d'intersection on va appeler ça
un quadrillage de points supposons que
l'on à un quadrillage de 10 points sur
10 points la question est la suivante
combien y at-il de carré comme celui là
dont les sommets sont des points du
quadrillage alors surtout ne mettez pas
la réponse dans les commentaires
histoire de laisser chacun cherchait
dans son coin de toute façon je
supprimerai tout commentaire qui suggère
une réponse si vous voulez proposer
votre réponse je vous invite à remplir
le google forme dont le lien est en
descriptions et le dimanche 12 novembre
à 18 heures je tirerai un vainqueur au
hasard parmi ceux qui ont donné bien sûr
la bonne réponse et qui auront aussi
fourni leur adresse email et
j'annoncerai ce vainqueur dans la vidéo
réponse le lundi 13 novembre à 18 heures
et ce grand vainqueur recevra deux
places pour tlx saclay le 30 novembre
prochain
dernière chose est un petit truc
piégé dans ce problème histoire de vous
aider à éviter le piège j'ai caché un
petit indice sur le site de tedx à clé